[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
territoire connectés et protection des
populations
en 2020 la ville d'istres a été la
première commune de france à équiper sa
police municipale de drones qui
permettent l'identification des auteurs
de méfaits en temps réel mais aussi une
surveillance plus efficace des massifs
forestiers dans le cadre de la
prévention des incendies
en matière de prévention des risques la
ville d'ajaccio a également innové en
déployant dès 2019 une plateforme
multicanal de téléalerte afin de
prévenir sa population en cas de crise
acteurs publics de terrain les élus
locaux sont ainsi inventeur de solutions
en matière de sécurité civile et de
prévention des risques dans les
territoires
c'est la conclusion à laquelle sont
parvenus antoine lefèvre anne catherine
loisier et jean yves roux auteur du
rapport territoire connectés et
protection des populations les élus
inventeur de solutions fait au nom de la
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et rendu public le 20
janvier 2022
sur le fondement de leurs observations
au sein des territoires les rapporteurs
ont formulé des recommandations visant
d'une part à encourager et sécuriser ces
initiatives numériques locales et
d'autre part à supprimer ou limiter
d'éventuels entraves à leur expression
avant tout les auteurs du rapport
préconisent d'informer les habitants sur
les risques auxquels ils sont exposés et
sur le bilan coût avantages des
solutions technologiques adopté
les rapporteurs souhaite par ailleurs
que les usagers bénéficient d'un niveau
optimal de protection et d'une mise à
jour permanente des systèmes de
protection des données
la mission préconise également de suivre
avec vigilance l'expérimentation du
recours aux drones par les services de
police municipale
en outre la mission conseil de confier
la compétence numérique à l'échelon qui
assure la meilleure veille technologique
qui dispose des meilleures compétences
et qui est le plus efficace en termes de
cybersécurité
enfin les sénateurs soulignent que la
coopération entre les collectivités
territoriales et les services
déconcentrés de l'état mériterait d'être
renforcé
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales
[Musique]